تعاهد قاده المجموعه دول السبعه الصناعيه
الكبرى بتزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه وقدرات
للدفاع الجوي بحث قاده مجموعه دول
الصناعيه سبعه في اجتماع عبر تقنيه
الفيديو بمشاركه الرئيس الاوكرانيه
امكانيه فرض عقوباتنا اكثر صلابه على
روسيا وتقديم المزيد من المساعده
لاوكرانيا واكد المجتمعون الالتزامهم
بالعقوبه غير المسبوقه التي فرضوها على
روسيا اقل المستشار الالماني نقاده دول
سبع اتفقوا على انشاء منصه لتنسيق
المساعدات الماليه لاوكرانيا
تجاذب حاجه
مجموعه الدول السبع الكبرى اليوم على
العناصر الرئيسيه لمنصه من اجل تنسيق
الدعم المالي لجميع المانحين الهدف هو
بناء هذه المنصه بسرعه بمشاركه اوكرانيا
والمؤسسات الماليه الدوليه والشركاء
الاخرين لقد اصبحت اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
مهمه الانسانيه لربما يمكن مقارنتها بخطه
مارشال بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه في
الوقت نفسه ابقينا الضغط الاقتصاديه على
روسيا عاليه مع ادخال سعر النفط اتخذنا
خطوه مهمه لتقليس عائده
في الوقت نفسه نسعى لضمان استقرار سوق
النفط العالميه ومواجهه الاسعار بشكل مفرد
وكانت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ايضا موضوع
اجتماعا في بروكسل وزراء خارجيه دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي الذين اتفقوا على تخصيص
اكثر من ملياريه يورو لدعم اكياف عسكريه
قال مفاوض السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
جوزيف بوريل ان خلافات حاله دون فرض حزمه
تاسعه من العقوبات على روسيا حدث بريل
خلال مؤتمر صحفيا عن ارجاء الامر لمزيدا
من النقاش خلال الايام المقبله
فيديو اندرويد
حول الحزمه التاسعه من العقوبات للرد على
تصعيد بوت تجاره اوكرانيا لم يصل الوزراء
الى الاتفاق ولكن امن اي يحدث ذلك خلال
هذا الاسبوع بل امن ان يكون خلال الساعات
المقبله او كحد اغصان نهايه الاسبوع
وافقنا في المقابل على عقوبه تجاه افراد
وكيانات اخرى
والجيش الروسي